matthieu delormeau je me suis retrouvé
tout nu à l'accueil d'un club de sport
oui c'est vrai qu'est ce qui va vous
avez perdu votre slip alors on va jouer
un jeu donc c'est les petits malheurs
des chroniqueurs dans l'écran vont
apparaître des petits malheurs subis par
les chroniqueurs vous allez devoir
retrouver à qui c'est arrivé d'accord se
sont guère que des vraies histoires qui
s'est fait emboutir sa voiture par un
car de crs à votre avis ici autour de la
table sachez que c'est une femme
voilà c'est une femme moi je dirais que
c'est valérie et bc valérie benaïm
rouaix
donc vous êtes fait emboutir mais s'est
fait emboutir mais ma voiture sur buttes
bien non mais j'étais voilà c'est un
étudiant du côté de la sorbonne est en
fait il y avait un carrefour et les en
fait le quart n'avait pas mis le
gyrophare ils sont partis en mission les
a appelés sur un truc et moi je restais
tranquillement avec ma bagnole l'aimé
mais quand il se dit qu'ils vont
exploser la voiture ils m'ont exploser
la voiture y en a un qui est sorti en
courant
on est en mission démerdez-vous est sûr
partie et m'ont laissée avec la voiture
explosée et il a fallu que j'aille en
fait au commissariat le plus proche pour
dire ben voilà c'est le début d'une
personne me croyais dans le commissariat
et les types ont été aussi d'appeler en
dix ans et nous voilà est donc belle et
si j'avais toujours eu de la chance qui
est passée sous un camion et a atterri
dans une librairie c'est un garçon
gérard non c'est pas pire année jamais
passé sous un canon déjà ça passerait
pas
je courais je suis tombé sur le trottoir
comme ça et en fait j'ai pris de la
vitesse en longeant la route le nez et
d'abandonner en avant tout en arrivant
et je suis passé entre les deux essieux
du camion j'ai repris de la vitesse je
me suis propulsé dans les cartes
postales de la librairie comme ça je
suis arrivé le chauffeur du camion était
paniqué ma mère pas vite et j'avais eu
quoi vous avez quel âge tu y avait sept
ans je crois ah ouais d'accord j'ai
quand même été un peu heurté un je suis
resté dans les toilettes pendant trois
heures j'étais à vsd un samedi matin et
donc je vais aux toilettes sphère
publique et de toilettes
écoutez je fais un peu et rentrent sains
de directeur du journal qu'il n'était
pas avec celle a-team bah oui ou d'un
moment j'entends quelques bruits quel
joli et faire des deuxièmes de quoi ah
oui on la personne était venu manger une
dalle est dans les toilettes
bien plus la tête qui cogné contre eux
contre la vie enfin une grosse commande
donc au bout de trois quarts d'heure ça
se terminait donc ce qui arrive c'est
qu'après il a envie d'aller aux
toilettes il va pour ouvrir et il sent
que c'est fermé et à l'horreur on sent
qu'ils y [ __ ] ya quelqu'un qui est
d'autant que tout oran et donc il a
attendu il est sorti et je sentais
qu'ils attendaient dehors pour voir qui
allait sortir et keroro témoins donc je
suis resté je les entendais respirer
d'hommes jeudi faut que je reste a duré
de 9h à 12h vision de l'histoire
même quand on bat honnête que pour faire
pipi on peut être sacrément emmerdé
matthieu delormeau je me suis retrouvé
tout nu à l'accueil d'un club de sport
oui c'est vrai qu'est ce qui va vous
avez perdu votre slip mais non mais vous
arrivez au sport m'a dit on des zones à
plus de serviettes bon je n'avais pas
grave
j'y suis allé quand même j'ai fait du
sport et après je fais les premiers d'où
j'ai tout mis dans le casier j'ai fermé
à clé et je les prends une douche en
sortant du coup je me suis dit alors
l'idée brillante de me sécher au
sèche-cheveux vous savez ces chemins
voilà et donc comme j'avais ma clé avec
moi
eh bien j'avais bien mettre quelque part
bouger les mis au dessus juste sèche et
il est tombé dedans donc là j'étais
totalement à poil ah ouais donc là je me
suis dit qu'est ce que je peux faire
dont j'ai commencé à me balader m petit
puff
non le dans le vestiaire dont forcément
les regards étaient un peu ce pays
d'autant que je précise que j'étais déjà
un petit peu si peu connu donc voilà
donc tout cas et des questions
je précise que j'étais nue mais j'étais
surtout connue chez nous je suis sorti
du vestiaire
donc comme ça avec les deux mains était
nécessaire non une censure et je suis
allé discrètement à l'accueil suis passé
devant pas mal de colère tu peux vous
auriez pu prendre un cendrier men et à
laquelle j'aurais demandé donc une pince
monseigneur pour aller casser
je croyais au début il est arrivé à vous
avez une place monseigneur quoi là c'est
pour me faire circoncire
[Musique]